the golden knights introducing their
third head coach in about six years time
that's right sports director chris
matthews was there this morning at city
national arena when bruce cassidy was
officially paraded into city national
arena chris only got for guy bruce
cassidy tells us what his plans will be
for the knights he was a defensive
minded coach with boston his offense
will be an attacking type offense up and
down the ice very quickly kind of like
that
bill foley kind of preaches that right
as a knight always attacking never
retreating he says he has a high end
defense as well and the key perhaps will
be of course his special teams play
putting teams on their heels always
attacking he has a history of successful
special teams play back in the 80s he
was a player but not a very good hockey
player he says but he was a power play
specialist
i wasn't a a great hockey player by any
means but the one strength i had i could
see the ice and i was a decent power
play guy so for me it's always been
something i've just gravitated towards
and you know lastly you're dealing with
your a lot of high-end players on a
daily basis i think that's important for
the head coach to connect with those
guys as well and share ideas so you can
build some trust in them
all right